the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think about all the Hong Kong [ __ ] then
I am so hopeful for the people of Hong
Kong and I talked about in my show
nightshade constantly my hope is it
reminds me of Poland 1989
right in Poland 1989 you had this big
labor movement solidarity they weren't
conservatives they were lefties they
were labour and they were like look the
Constitution says we have democratic
elections and you have them there's only
one candidate let's have elections let's
have elections and the cotton Margaret
Thatcher came there supported them she
was loved in the Eastern Bloc so the
Polish Communist Party sat down and
they're like alright let's have these
elections and then there were some
little bit worried that well what if we
win all the elections because they asked
the people who you're gonna vote for oh
the Communists the communist communist
the elections happen the Labour
Solidarity wins every seat except one
and the question is are they gonna honor
this what are they going to wave it away
they honored it and that was the
beginning of the end of the Soviet Union
I don't think you could have Tiananmen
Square today because Tiananmen Square
was before smartphones Tiananmen Square
was before the internet there's no
footage tank man wasn't killed he was
pulled away Hong Kong we're seeing the
footage and when you see kids getting
beaten and tear gassed you don't need to
speak any language to look at and be
like something's not right here
and decide with the people who are
getting beaten this is a very Martin
Luther King thing like even the racists
were like I don't want these people to
have dogs attacking them in water hoses
this is outrageous
mmm yeah so I'm very very hopeful this
is going to work positively to start the
end of the you know evil Chinese
dictatorship I hope you're right I hope
you're right and that would also work
towards liberating North Korea which is
obviously that issue do you think that
it's possible for China to ever turn it
around though forget about the Hong Kong
but mainland China turn what around we
turn what around in terms of their whole
dictatorship oh yeah Russia the Soviet
Union did it but did they yes did they
yeah you a puppet of Putin as well he's
my uncle I mean it kind of did it but
they're kind of a dictatorship right now
you can you can get a passport you're
not gonna get your organs hard
instead who got a passport who ride
Jones jr. Roy Jones jr. who's that who
the [ __ ] are you man I'm a piece of [ __ ]
was never was snatched dude
Roy Jones jr. is one of the greatest
boxers of all time okay he won the super
middleweight championship went up to the
light heavyweight and heavyweight okay
he beat John Ruiz to win the heavyweight
championship a guy who fought at 168
pounds okay he's a beast okay sure
he's one of the greatest of all time and
he also has a Russian passport okay okay
that's awesome but the point is people
can leave Russia people can't leave
China and now they're going in a bad
direction with North Korea instituting
their social credit system to control
internal migration which is really
really bad what do you think about
people being able to go back and forth
like like what do you think about travel
back and forth from Russia into the
United States I mean they must be like
watching every single thing you do I
don't think it's as pervasive listen you
know what they're watching everything we
do here come on what do you think about
Snowden being over there I think I I
think ed Snowden should be allowed to
walk free I think so too I mean and and
yeah it's it's insane that we drove him
into the hands of the Soviet Union and
what he was exposing was illegal
activity he was officials Stalin in his
wildest dreams and his KGB never had
that power of surveillance like Ed
Snowden revealed that every single cell
phone is being hacked into are they
recording literally every call yeah I
mean it's it's and we just said we're
like oh this is fine
tracking aids it's just the level of
talk about right to privacy the level of
surveillance that this government is
putting forward is insane it is crazy
and remember when Obama ranted about is
like just metadata no worries yeah it's
fine I just trust us does metadata yeah
we're just collecting metadata and he's
and swats Nonna's like no no I was
reading people's emails right yeah we
all read emails and there was some
report I forgot her name like they were
deleted she was on her computer and you
could see the file being deleted right
in front of her she's a good video with
her camera yeah cuz she was breaking
this stuff
Harris listen if 4chan can get into your
that hacker 4chan can get into your
computer they can of course I've done
and of course they do but I mean it's
you think about that before you Google
things oh that ship has sailed
that that's all that's gonna be a
problem oh that's gonna be a problem oh
oh no oh no oh there's a nope no that's
another one
[Applause]